[Music]
am I the [ __ ] news submitted by come
back to Europe Joe whoo an air B&B guest
claims his host threatened to report him
for not showering before going to bed
how would they know maybe they stink
with the host complained about the
guests or they guests complained about
the host Dan that's how bad they smell
they stained the bed holy there are
people like that there are people like
that yeah they can do some damage oh
that's so tell me I'm wrong big stinky
Dan oh yeah real stink bombs all right
so this was posted on reddit subreddit
and might be [ __ ] and the title is mi
the [ __ ] for sleeping after a long
plane journey instead of showering and
this is what they wrote I a 26 year old
male tried out Airbnb for the first time
on a recent trip to New York I was
staying in my host a 24 year old female
bedroom while she bunked with her
roommates oh they have higher standards
white females oh yeah good night picky
if you're staying with females you
better you better you better take a shot
at that first oh I was trying to clarify
well yeah like those boys wouldn't go to
a boy's room and it smells like feet
like it always suppose like feet like
well why what did you do in their house
like ass I know yeah you'd like once you
live with a woman it all sudden your
room smells like flowers and
wonderfulness
except for my sign yeah hey shut it you
guys smell amazing I don't know how you
are I mean like in the in the female
okay okay so anyway so he continuous I
arrived after an eight-hour flight at
what would be around 3:00 a.m. my time
but 10:00 p.m. in New York I met my host
who showed me around quickly pointing
pathetically because he's fake yeah
pointing out the bathroom and the
bedroom I told her it was exhaust
mystically the showers these are the
shower works which is also known as baby
popper
sorry I told you I was exhausted so I
just went so I just wanted to go to bed
I fell asleep almost immediately and
then I woke about 4 a.m. New York time I
was I and I discovered a handwritten
note had been slid under my door
the note read as follows hi this might
be your first time doing Airbnb so you
should understand a few standard
etiquettes Airbnb is hosting so it is
very different from a hotel or motel you
need to keep the room clean and free of
odor because you are staying in someone
else's room after your flight you had a
strong odor yet you didn't take a shower
before going to bed as the owner of the
room the bed and the sheets
I am extremely displeased with this fact
wow you didn't respect the cleanliness
of my room please keep this in mind
during your stay I might have to report
to Airbnb if you fail to keep up with
the personal hygiene and lower the
quality of my room Thanks so then he
finishes up with I'm a shower in the
morning person I never really showered
before bed I also think that if you're
worried about people's funk don't rent
your room outside actually that's true
yeah he's right about that
he's known Asti though he's an aster
also give benefit the doubt that they
can fix the situation like before
writing a note like the next morning
yeah or no the night in the nola night
maybe he took a shower or maybe he
stumped that bad or maybe this chick is
so obsessed she's got a glass up against
the wall she's like pause [ __ ]
not showering dude my brother had a foot
fungus and when he stayed with us it was
disgusting it smelled up the whole house
smell attacks without someone with a
foot fungus before they leave ghosts
stink on the floor yes we'd like be
pleased to get it out yeah we got
disgusting I'd having a conversation
with him I was like you're never gonna
get cuz he was like I don't know what
how could a girlfriend I'm like this is
disgusting this is like the worst I have
ever smelled smells like sour after
shower raffle and you can smell it from
deep into our
so I get that however I would give
benefit the doubt if if like that person
could clean it up to buy the morning
time I wouldn't slip it into their room
how would they even know their smell
true if they're used to a lot of people
don't know it's true my brother got used
to it and then they know who to blame in
this information he was it it smells
like a [ __ ] band-aid yeah well this
guy's nasty for sure but she's also a
[ __ ] - yeah this is two extremes of
people yeah I don't think this chicks a
[ __ ] only because I've had to dealt
with I've had to deal with smelly people
and it is look it's very selfish to not
clean yourself if you're renting a thing
out - call it the territory if you're in
convincing people that hardware they
cave and be around you but you isolate
yourself or in a room to people you they
don't even know they smell problems they
don't know the person renting the Airbnb
dude there was this guy that set next to
us on the plane he was like this kid he
was like 18 years old last year coming
back from playlist and he had bad
halitosis and like every time I tell sis
oh but like extremely bad breath so
every time he breathed out like he would
just be breathing normally with greeting
a book the entire row was just smell
like diarrhea it was just you didn't
vote like this every time you were I was
like this the whole time I was like yeah
like that the whole time we had to vote
it was that bad the guy behind me flying
back from Japan smelled like diarrhea I
think you should have oh yeah we could
have had bad breath that smelled like
that area that's true smells okay yeah
that's not so what happened I mean it's
just uh just to end it so then he says I
also think that you're worried about
people's funk don't rent out your room
to others I mean I get it nobody wants
to smell your room but I assume she
changes the sheets when someone stays
anyway I'm not I've not been able to
stop thinking about the handwritten note
since I got it so I thought I'd share it
with the internet so the the subreddit
concluded that he is not the [ __ ] hmm
I disagree I'd have to smell it first
I'm so predisposed to not liking smelly
people meet you yeah I just that a lot
of these smelly people are just [ __ ]
up but what if they don't know
they smell that the problem right if you
tell them that they smell and then they
don't fix it because they don't wash the
clothes or what and they're the [ __ ]
and they are the [ __ ] what if you
have a very sensitive nose and you can
pick up on everything but if other
people have confirmed they're just in a
room with everybody and they're that
smelling mm-hmm you start seeing people
go like this yeah yeah like you're that
and you're not doing it yes you're the
[ __ ] every [ __ ] time there's guys
that'll take off their shoes in front of
you and let their stench [ __ ] Road
are in a plane at a library you're
headed you ready I feel like it's you do
your food that I don't have people going
oh your food tastes like whatever they
smell like oh do you eat around them I
don't want any lunch or undo smelly
stuff I think it's like this it's like
if you're an [ __ ]
right and people might not tell you're
an [ __ ] but it's still your fault but
you should still know that you're being
an [ __ ] to the world like your
personality's like that that's the same
with stench no it's not other people's
job to tell you that you stink you
should know that you stink what did they
tell you you should try to fix it
obviously is it 3:00 a.m. his time 10:00
a.m. newer time I wonder where he was
with you so I wonder where he was coming
from if it was 3:00 a.m. his time
because culturally like some places in
Europe and India like different places
like they everybody smells a certain way
so like they don't stand out as smelling
particularly like a long ass like yeah
so I want like where is this person from
because maybe culturally like like a
political all places in Europe they
don't do deodorant so culturally my ass
in France I heard that they don't use
get they did stink over there so maybe
this French they smelled like cigarettes
and perfume and human sweat we never
should have saved them in ww2 WWC never
shoulda w toe yeah I don't know
reading this I was kind of conflicted
because like I don't know like I get for
the guy it's like well [ __ ] you know I'm
tired I just had a long-ass flight yeah
maybe I might be a little stinky but the
[ __ ] you're writing out your room deal
with it I think they're both right being
one wrong for personal reasons and the
other one is wrong for business reasons
yeah if your bed is gonna be a hotel now
you got to get one of those like you
know a little spill proof the plastic
and down on the pillowcase so that even
when you after you remove a sheets and
you go in like frickin I have some Glade
plugins or some Febreze or some shade
all right either that's like the risk
that you take yeah and I've been
watching these like air B&B horror
stories from like horror to the host
where they don't leave because like some
like swatting yeah oh no like some laws
in some states that like you're not
protected in your own home against
people [ __ ] squatting in your home
we're like these people couldn't kick
them out nightmare I would never do it
uh-uh sounds like a California thing
maybe can you scare them out I don't
know with an elaborate perhaps goes to
[Laughter]
[Music]
hire a burglar like a like someone that
has guns and knives run out I hire like
a local I don't know a football team or
some [ __ ] like the like high school
football team I dressed them up like
mutant motorcyclists mm-hmm invade my
home like a zombie tank oh yeah but
mutant bikers is a very scary thing hmm
I never thought of that I spend a lot of
money renting these motorcycles Oh true
spending a lot of money cuz they're
eating all your food and stuff being at
your house and your Airbnb cuz like
these people these videos I was watching
they were just making themselves at home
eating all the food in the cabinet Oh
[ __ ] lounging in the living room
kicking up their feet on the sofa yeah
but what happens when they leave for
Christmas you can play change the locks
they leave what they leave for Christmas
they just sit there
yeah they don't leave at all period no
like they're like these gold Google it
means hoarder they are are they there
for like months oh my god and they're
like they're all in that place can't do
it you can't call the cops
they go to a grocery store some [ __ ] cuz
I guess if you see there a certain
amount of time you're legally a tenant
and so after being a tenant you can't
get kicked out cuz like they protect
they know these loopholes and they're
just like [ __ ] it so if you stay a
certain amount of time nightmare I'm so
petty though Airbnb just charge them for
all that time no it was like there's
like a loophole and they probably fixed
the rules since these videos came out
but they're pretty much it's all [ __ ]
petty though I'd get a hose and fill my
house up with water you destroy your own
home yeah I mean you could hire a band
to play at 2:00 a.m. it's noise
pollution we call the cops on you you
could invite your stinky friend over oh
yeah have him walk around with the goats
in their room oh that's that's pretty
strong take the hose in his but I don't
have options we have option at least if
I filled my house with water I could do
what I always dreamed of doing for a
little while before I have a pool in
your living room we have a sunken living
room too so it would be like a little
bit of a pool I'll be sick right and
then harsh reality yeah Wow
[Music]